The universe is full of amazing contrasts.
Most of space expanses are code lifeless,
vacuum paradoxically.
It harbors clumps of surprisingly hot material, which were call stars,
drifting deliberately through its limitless stretches for billions of years.
The Illumina, the farther steps of space and undergo slow and mostly subtle
changes as time goes by. However,
sometimes space is illuminated with an incredibly big flash.
A giant star suddenly shrinks to a thousandth of its original size only to
destroy everything around it in a violent explosive moments.
Later the shockwave with a power beyond our imagination,
rips the star apart and with its volume blown away and gone.
The only things that remain around are clumps of scorching hot gas.
And by the star has just been there remains just a tiny object made up of
exceptionally dense material with bizarre and extraordinary properties.
This is how stars die violently and in the blink of an eye.
The end of 2019 astronomical observator ripped port a sudden decrease
in the luminosity of the star,
known as beetle juice observations show that its luminosity dropped to
36% of the standard value. Within a matter of a couple of months,
some scientists are talking about an upcoming supernova,
which will be the brightest object in the night sky disturbingly.
The gamma Ray flow emitted by the explosion is thought to be potentially
dangerous for life on our planet. April,
2020 astronomers assure the general public that beetle juice has recovered its
luminosity to the standard value. It may still go soup and over at any moment,
but there is no way to predict this event with any degree of certainty
assumptions about reasons for such anomalous fading had put forward.
According to the most popular hypothesis,
it was caused by a giant cloud of gas and dust ejected by beetle juice in the
direction of the sun. Very recently, June, 2021,
the assumption is confirmed by data from earth-based telescopes,
astronomers,
keep observing the object while astrophysicists model allow the processes
occurring in its interior.
Before we attempt to get to the bottom of what was taking place,
it's a good idea to be aware of what beetle juice is like.
This object falls into the category of red super giants and is on the final
stage of its slide life cycle.
According to today's theory of stellar evolution with its luminosity and
radius constantly changing its out layers are highly unstable.
The star regularly meets millions of tons of scorching gas into space and this
forms Gargan and prominences as they cool off,
they contribute to the gas Nebula surrounding beetle juice.
The Star's mass is around 17 times that the sun and is diameter has by
now been engaged early,
roughly at 700 to 880 times out of the sun.
Hypothetically, if beetle juice were to be placed in the center of our system,
it would swallow up all the planets as far as Mars,
as well as most of the asteroid belt.
It should be mentioned that the star has no clearly defined edge because it,
so layers are extremely ratified.
The besides the object is shrouded in a Gargan and gas Nebula
made up of cooled off prominences or protuberances and particles of stellar
wind. At the same time,
the density of stellar matter on the conventional edges of the star is only
slightly higher than that than Nebula beetle juice is a remarkably bright
star.
Its minimal luminosity is 90,000 times higher than that of the sun while
it's maximum luminosity is a staggering 150,000 times higher.
Interestingly, the stars, temperatures,
not that great considering it ranges from 3,400 to
3,800 Calvin, which corresponds to the red spectral band.
There are barely predictable processes running in the unstable outer layers of
the star. They're capable of elaborately changing the objects. Luminosity.
The main pulsation period of the star is approximately 420 days,
but less distinct cycles of longer and smaller period.
Rids can be singled out too.
Besides unpredictable flares and dimming of the star can be observed from time
to time because this star is so unstable.
It is extremely difficult to calculate the distance between us.
According to the estimates offered by the Coreys satellite in 2020,
the distance between the sun and beetle G is anything from 500 to
650 light years.
According to today's notions of stellar evolution, beetle juice,
would've formed around eight and a half million years ago and its original mass
wouldn't have been over 20 solar masses, its life cycle.
Would've started in a giant cloud of inter stellar gas that have been gradually
compressed and heated out by gravity forces. That is how the produce star,
the progenitor of beetle juice was born at a certain point.
The temperature and pressure in its interior reached high enough values to
unleash a chain reaction of hydrogen transforming into helium moments later,
the thermonuclear interaction,
the entire astronomical body and a new star flare up in the night sky.
This is how the longest period in the life of any star begins.
The main sequence stage throughout this time merging of hydrogen
atoms nuclear that produce helium is the main energy source for them.
Admittedly, the heavier a star,
the faster this process runs life expectancy of massive stars like beetle juice
is a measly several million years where RA red dwarves remain active for
billions of years,
either way over 90% of a Star's life passes in the main
sequence stage.
Gradually accumulating helium is drawn to the object center to form
helium core.
What happens to this star next depends almost entirely on its mass.
For example, stars with masses,
not over 20% scent that of the sun did not go super and over at the end of their
existence. Unlike more massive stars,
having eventually run out of almost all of their hydrogen,
they slowly turn into glued wolves,
hot and comparatively small astronomical objects. However,
the minimal time it takes to complete this transformation is around a trillion
years, which is 72 times the soon age of the universe,
which is why it is doubtful that any blue dwarf will be discovered today.
After hydrogen supplies are depleted thermonuclear reactions and the star will
stop and it will become a wide dwarf made up of 99% of helium
ahead are trillions of years of slow fading and cooling until a tepid
blacked whaf is left instead, which is barely visible through telescopes.
If an objects mass lies on the range from 0.2 to eight, solar masses,
its evolution goes through more elaborate processes, helium,
which is produced as result of thermonuclear reactions adds to the Star's core
while gravity forces compress it and heat it up more and more.
At a certain point there occurs a reaction of helium nucle merging,
which produces carbon.
The star begins to expand its radius grows as well.
And the temperature of the outer layers drops in the, this case.
The object turns into a red giant or sub giant comparatively light
stars with masses,
not exceeding 50% that of the sun can sustain conditions necessary for the
chain reaction of helium and carbon transformations.
Like these are quite irregular in such objects as for heavier objects
occurring.
The stars' core may run longer and produce not early carbon and oxygen,
but also heavier elements like nickel and Diane.
Eventually the star sheds its outta layers.
And what is left is a wide dwarf enveloped in a planetary Nebula.
If the initial mass of the original star wasn't more than half that of the sun,
it will mostly be made up of helium with just a small ratio of heavier relevance
in its composition. If on the other hand, the star was heavier than that.
The white dwarf would be mostly made up of oxygen and carbon. However,
with the original star having been heavy enough,
it will include neon magnesium and even iron evolution
of massive objects has its laws. The heavier star,
the more massive its core,
what the massive a star ate or more times that of the sun its core might get
over with the so-called ch shaker limit,
which is 1.4 times the mass of the sun in this case,
forces of internal electromagnetic repulsion are not strong enough to compensate
for gravitational compression.
It takes a few seconds for the core to shrink pulling the outer layers in its
wake.
The exceptionally powerful compression heats up the core to temperatures of
hundreds of millions Kelvin and literally crowns electrons into atom's NLE.
This turns part of the electrons into neutrons and produces great amounts of
Neu trios,
even a dense material like that is not able to hold back the most elusive
particle in the universe in a few seconds,
star neutrinos break away from the collapsing star and escape taking some
thermal energy with them. As a result,
the star experience is extremely powerful.
Internal pressure as the closely packed pros,
repair each other with a great force.
That is why the core goes on to expand as rapidly as it shrank of fewer
previously.
And this produces a tremendous shockwave in the material surrounding it.
As a result, a tremendously powerful explosion occurs,
which is capable of hurling the stars outta layers,
enormous distances away its flames can unleash reactions that are
impossible anywhere else.
That is how heavy elements are produced like gold lead or uranium.
The Nebula formed as a byproduct gradually cools off and disperses to form
separate clouds,
which are later compressed by gravity forces and transforming in used stars and
planets where the star has been.
There remains a tiny but extremely the object referred to as a neutron star.
If the original stars mass was over 18 to 20 times outta the sun on
explosion, its core is supposed to shrink to form a black hole,
a bizarre object that distorts time and space around it.
Mathematical modeling shows that particularly large stars with masses over a
hundred times,
the mass of the sun may hypothetically be destroyed by the blast completely.
In this case,
all the material they're made up of will be scattered by the shock wave.
Many light years around or else be transformed into extremely powerful
electromagnetic radiation.
An electromagnetic impulse from a super over is capable of covering hundreds of
light years. At first,
the radiation is characterized by incredible force annihilating,
all living things on its way. However,
with the covered distance growing the density of the flow decreases and the
lethal rays gradually disperse in space estimates show that a star
similar to beetle juice may be a threat to anything the radius of up to a
hundred light years.
It is absolutely impossible to tell when this star will go supernova,
but it is likely to do so in the nearest a hundred thousand years,
according to some estimates,
beetle juice may flare up as brightly as the full moon.
The dying star will remain the dominating object in our night sky for a while,
and then will gradually fade.
The object will not be visible to the naked eye anymore. And dearly.
The most powerful telescopes will be able to distinguish the radiation emitted
by the tiny neutron star.
If the massive beetle juice is actually bigger than is assumed.
Now it may leave a black hole after going super over in this
scenario,
the energy flare will be by far smaller and the site much less impressive.
The either way,
there is no threat to the earth beetle juice lies too far away from the solar
system and a Gama Ray flat will accompany the Soen over will not cause us
any harm.
The material ejected by the explosion will reach the environs of our system only
in 6 million years.
Its speed is estimated to be around 13 per second and will be
thwarted by solar wind before getting as far as the inner areas of the system
with all today's successes in science, the dark depths of limitless space,
still Harbor myriads of mysteries and hazards.
That is why people keep studying the sky is diligently a thousands of years ago
in search of answers to their questions.
And the gloomy boundless of inter Stella space is as scary as it
is appealing.
Who knows maybe at some point it will provide an answer to a
really major question.
I.